willkommen liebe zuschauer bei history
live den historischen quartett auf
phoenix napoli gewann oder reformer
darüber diskutieren wir heute 200 jahre
nach der schlacht von waterloo mit der
deutsch-amerikanischen historikerin
karin hagemann von der universität north
carolina in chapel hill und der american
academy hier in berlin den historiker
etienne francois von frankreich zentrum
der freien universität berlin und den
historiker marian füssel von der
georg-august-universität in göttingen
vor allem anna napoleon schieden sich
bereits zu lebzeiten die geister und sie
tun es immer noch die einen sahen und
sehen in ihm vor allen dingen den
reformer die anderen eher den tyrannen
was stimmt denn nun
beides das ist sicher eine antwort die
auf den ersten blick und befriedend ist
aber befriedigend es aber in der tat war
er beides hat die politische landschaft
europas die das gesetz wesen europas in
einem pro forma schon sinne anschließend
an die französische revolution verändert
weitreichend verändert und zugleich hat
er mit seiner militärischen imperialen
wie wir heute sagen macht politik war
auch ein touran er hat unter anderem
diese reformen auch im militärbereich
oder den finanzbereich mit einem
staatswesen durchgeführt um auch die
kriege zunehmend zu finanzieren und hier
länger die kriege gedauert haben desto
mehr wurde er vor allem in den
okkupierten regionen ja und man muss da
wirklich die dimension sehen den
okkupierten regionen ist auch als tyrann
wahrgenommen und auch so bezeichnet
wurden also in der zeitgenössischen
propaganda preußens oder österreichs
oder russlands und auch großbritanniens
wurde er heißt die rand bezeichnet immer
wieder und als teufel und also als
inkarnation des bösen die karriere
unseres helden war ja voll mindernd ein
unbekannter mann aus korsika wird binnen
weniger jahre
herrscher über frankreich und europa wie
war so etwas möglich
da sind zwei gründe zu nennen das
militär war immer schon ein kanal
sozialer mobilität als alle junger
artillerie offizier der sich gut bewährt
hat hat er alle möglichkeiten des
aufstiegs innerhalb der militärischen
hierarchie in der evolution kriege wurde
permanent krieg geführt man braucht also
solche tatkräftigen heerführer wieder
polen es war und natürlich die
tatsächlichen politischen krisen
umbrüche die unheimlichen dynamik
derzeit macht es solchen aufsteigern
möglich selbst sozusagen ein mann der
tat zu sein und durch einfach fakten zu
schaffen und durch diese erfolge die er
dann auch sehr geschickt
propagandistisch aus gemünzt hat sich
als die person zu empfehlen in dem
französischen volk die den weg in die
zukunft weisen wird 200 jahre waterloo
fonds war diese schlacht erhitzt ja
offenkundig noch immer die gemüter wie
man kürzlich sehen konnte als paris in
brüssel bei der europäischen union
protestierte damit belgien keine münze
aus gab die anatoliens niederlage
erinnerte wie stark ist denn der
nationalstolz der franzosen auf napoleon
noch immer der polio gehört in
frankreich zu den drei beliebtesten
historischen persönlichkeiten zusammen
mit general de gaulle und mit ludwig dem
vierzehnten weil alle 3 und das gilt
nicht nur für eine polio verkörpern eine
mischung aus glanz und auf strahlung
nach außen und in einem land wie
frankreich wo man heute sehr an die
eigene zukunft zweifelt hier sind solche
persönlichkeiten 1 ausgleich man weiß
nicht wie die zukunft aussehen wird
jeder weiß in falkau dass frankreich
nicht mehr das führe land in europa war
wird vielleicht wieder wenn die
geburtenrate weiter so ist ja im
vergleich zu deutschland aber nicht im
vergleich zu den anderen
länder aber auf empfindlichen zu einer
zweiteiligen macht geworden ist trotzdem
bleibt etwas von einer strahlenden
ruhmreichen geschichte und das ist eine
form von trost
so würde sagen eine mischung aus trost
und abenteuergeschichte denn bei allem
negativen aspekten von napoleon worüber
wir sprechen werden bleibt napoleon
genie ohne zweifel und werde ich einen
vergleich mit deutschland zu ziehen
würde
ich würde ihn mit riedel zweiten
vergleichen der auch ein genie
sondergleichen war und auch ein feldherr
ohne rücksichten auf die verluste der
krieg nun war ja diese schnee doch ein
kind der französischen revolution
freiheit gleichheit brüderlichkeit
aber er erklärte sich ja irgendwann mal
einfach für beendet und ließ sich dann
zum kaiser krönen war dass zynismus oder
verrat an den idealen der revolution was
man wie ich glaube dass das in das
napoleon selber in gewisser weise sich
vorgestellt hat auch die ideale der
revolution fortzuführen zur enttäuschung
oder real
ich denke also ich halte hat probleme
mit dieser vorstellung dass solche
historischen figuren sich selbst
täuschen oder an ihre ideologie nur
ideologien sind ich glaube dass er
selber geglaubt hat und wenn man die
biographien dies dann deutet vieles
darauf hin dass er die revolution die
gedanken der revolution die ideale der
revolution fortgeführt hat und sozusagen
gleichzeitig modifiziert hat und ein
stück ruhe und größe wieder zurück
gebracht hat ich meine die revolution
war durchaus für für breite kreise der
französischen bevölkerung
etienne francois kann darf hier mehr zu
sagen aber eine krisenerfahrung das war
eine krisenhafte situation die
revolution kriege waren durchaus nicht
ungebrochen erfolgreich und insofern war
die sehnsucht in europa nicht nur in
frankreich an nach der jahrhundert
stabilität und stabilität wurde durchaus
durch könige und monarchien auf
repräsentiert also die idee in der
republik war nicht die ideen die von
allen auch schon gar nicht im
deutschsprachigen raum auch in
frankreich geteilt von ich denke dass er
wirklich geglaubt hat die ideen der
revolution vorzuführen und auf eine neue
ebene zu bringen
natürlich ist da auch bei sony das hat
charisma da ist natürlich auch die
sehnsucht nach größe nach verewigung in
der geschichte spielt sicher auch eine
rolle es hat viele dimensionen
aber ich denke dass das also dass man
das auch wieder ein stück erzählt sehen
muss und nicht diese dieses entweder
oder ist glaube ich zu einfach um ihn zu
verstehen
wir reden von stabilität dass die
menschen auch in frankreich erwähnt aber
war es denn stabilität wenn man die
söhne des landes durch halb europa jagt
all halb europa treibt auf die
schlachtfelder wo viele gestorben sind
war das stabilität
das begann mit stabilität und das war
stabilität bis zum ende in gewissen
hinsichten dann begann instabilität
zuerst weil napoleon als erster den
bürgerlichen frieden in frankreich
wieder hergestellt hat weil er einen
zahn starke unterstützung auch vom volk
hatte das ist eine primiz ehre macht die
er hat er hat das bestätigen lassen
durch die weder was kein anderer
machthaber in europa machen konnte und
er hat gleichzeitig mit der
wiederherstellung des bürgerlichen
inneren friedens in frankreich
institutionen geschaffen die so etwas
wie die grundpfeiler der französischen
gesellschaft und der französischen
struktur waren für die zeit wie auch bis
zu mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
die neuregulierung der finanzen die
schaffung des frau die neuordnung der
verwaltung und des justizwesen mit dem
chor zivile die neustrukturierung der
fall
haltung wie den präfekten mit der
spezialisierung mit einer geordneten
beamtenschaft das alles ist wichtig und
vergessen wir nicht napoleon hat zu
beginn den niveau der kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung mit europa router
gefahren
18.02 herrschte frieden überall auch mit
großbritannien
es gab ein jahr frieden in europa
zwischen 1802 und 1803 aber immerhin
immerhin der beginn war vielversprechend
und daran hat sich viele franzosen
geklammert
und als dann die kriege wieder begannen
die kriege wurden alle außerhalb von
frankreich durchgeführt die armeen waren
nicht so zahlreich und die siege von der
polizei waren so glänzend dass der
gewinn für frankreich und für die
franzosen auch im sinne von eroberung
und ausbeutung viel höher war als der
verlust
in anbetracht der verluste auf den
schlacht wenden
nun hat er dieser napoleon herr füssel
auch das heilige römische reich
deutscher nation wesentlich mit
zerschlagen
gleichwohl war er doch in deutschen
landen auch in seiner eigenen schöpfung
dem rhein bund zumindest am anfang jahr
in roma so populär
warum war das so weil er den kurzen
exportiert hat moderne gesetze die zum
beispiel juden auch nicht ausgrenzen
oder anderes mehr man ein großer fan war
ja zum beispiel goethe da kommt man ja
auch nicht von ungefähr drauf wie ist
das alles zu erklären
also in den deutschen ländern ist es so
dass es ein sehr heterogenes bild es
gibt ländern sehr beliebt war
es gibt andere in den das weniger der
fall war aber muss auch sozial
differenzieren zwischen dem
intellektuellen eliten die natürlich ein
ganz anderes interesse daran hatten
einen radikalen modernisierer zur
willkommenen der der also mit
den alten zöpfen des alten reiches
gewissermaßen aufbau der für
reformprojekte der überhaupt für
innovation in einer gewissen weise steht
wird hingegen die einfache bevölkerung
eine familie die ihre söhne an den krieg
verliert natürlich ganz andere gefühle
gegenüber den napoleon hatte den
beliebte und wo weniger
man kann das einerseits an der sozialen
leiter sagen dass es einen unter
bestimmten in die regionen über einen
regionen kann man es gar nicht so
einfach nicht sein es gab keine region
wo er total um beliefern regionen wo er
total beliebt war ich meine die regionen
die mit ihm gekämpft haben zum beispiel
bayern haben natürlich bis heute eine
ganz andere jetzt gerade mit großer
landesausstellung bayern ein ganz
anderes verhältnis zu napoleon als
regionen die er aus militärischer
ausplünderung konzeptionen zahlen und so
weiter betroffen waren also das ist je
nach betroffenheit ist auch ein rein
physisch materiell natürlich ganz
unterschiedlich wie beliebt oder
unbeliebte kaiser war und es hängt
natürlich auch in der zeitlichen
entwicklung davon ab in welchem jahren
wir jetzt sprechen das war also nicht zu
allen zeiten in deutschland dass der
polo wird gewissermaßen geteilt sondern
da gibt es große schwankungen die mit
den militärischen erfolgen und
misserfolgen einhergehen die auch
bedingt gewesen die die bevölkerung
erlebt einhergehen insofern ist das
nicht ganz eindeutig zu beantworten was
man sein könnte napoleon war in
württemberg beliebter als in westfalen
oder in preußen unbeliebter als in
norddeutschland sondern man muss nach
region zeit und vor allem
bevölkerungsgruppe über die man spricht
immer dann unterscheiden
man könnte problemlos ein bisschen
politik fiction machen
stellen sie uns vor polio hätte den
russlandfeldzug gewonnen
dann wäre ich bin davon ganz fest
überzeugt aus den vier debatte muss vom
linken rheinufer so etwas ein prozess
hätte sich entwickelt der durchaus
vergleichbar wäre mit dem prozess der
annäherung und der integration vom
elsass im königlichen frankreich im 17
jahrhundert also meiner heimatstadt
mainz wäre dann endgültig 20 uhr
einfach schon sehr französisch 1810 und
wie gesagt wenn der polio nicht so
tollkühn gewesen wäre und alle opfer
treten
das hätte dich vorgesetzt problemlos und
1820 als 130 wären alle bewohner dieser
region zweisprachig geworden und
überzeugte franzosen
wenn wir von diesen reformen sprechen
von denen herr fonds war geredet hat
civil zentralisierung der verwaltung
schaffen dass frau etc etc
war das nun edler selbstzweck oder war
das auch die schaffung eines möglichst
effektiven staates für weitere
eroberungen
das hängt ganz davon ab über welche
regionen wir sprechen also ich würde den
kollegen nicht ganz zustimmen ich denke
es gibt erhebliche regionale
unterschiede
dass die gebiete die zur konfiguration
eine reinigung zum rheinbund mein
englisch und deutsch zum rheinbund
gehört haben dass die stärker auch
profitiert haben dass dort auch die
reform wirklich zu einer erheblichen
modernisierung beigetragen haben aber
angetrieben und also auch durchgesetzt
wurden von der französischen seite sehr
stark auch um die kriege führen zu
kommen das heißt der krieg hat den krieg
ernährt und die reform waren auch im
finanzwesen zb waren er in erheblichem
maße notwendig um die kriegs
finanzierung zu ermöglichen
wenn wir uns preußen angucken oder noch
zum osten gehen oder auch österreich in
den blick nehmen ist das ganze ein
bisschen anders
preußen hat nach 18 6 18 7 das war eine
massive niederlage das ist auch so
wahrgenommen diskutiert worden
und das ist es geteilt worden ist es nur
rumpf preußen üblich gebricht geblieben
das land war besetzt das war okkupation
und wie wir heute wissen ob
kooperationen sind nie beliebt ja das
ist also wenn man wirklich
widerstandswillen kreieren will da muss
man ein land besetzen und möglichst
lange dort bleiben und auch möglichst
viel aus dem land heraus pressen und da
gibt es ganz viele berichte von
zeitzeugen der verschiedenen sozialen
schichten adel adels besitzer bis hin zu
den tagelöhnern die diese besetzung und
also auch die erzwungene das an zugende
bündnis immer mehr als drückend
empfunden haben das heißt er gibt schon
unterschiede und dort sind natürlich
interessanterweise auch reformen
vorgenommen worden mit dem ziel
sozusagen den dem dem der militärischen
und politischen herausforderungen die
durch frankreich und napoleon gestellt
wurde zu also begegnen zu können und was
wirklich interessant ist in bezug auf
die militärische seite ist es ist nicht
so sehr das die neue uniform sie haben
neue uniformen zum teil gehabt sie haben
nicht so sehr neue waffen gehabt
sie haben auch gar nicht so sehr neue
taktiken und strategien entwickelt es
waren die massen mit der einführung der
allgemeinen wehrpflicht haben die das
massen armeen gewesen wo gesellschaft
und staat in viel stärkerem maße
herausgefordert waren um die kriege zu
finanzieren und deshalb sozusagen auch
das war wirklich so in meiner oder auch
in unseren wir haben eine große
forschungs gehört das war
eine driving force eine wirklich eine
der treibenden kräfte die diese reform
angetrieben hat ja und insofern stelle
ich natürlich mich selbst auch ein
bisschen in frage weil ich vorher gesagt
hab ja er war reform aber er war ein
reformer der auch eine bestimmte putten
politisches programm hatte und also
wirklich auf die notwendigkeiten seine
imperialen politik sehr geschickt
reagiert hatte dieser napoleon denn ein
großes ziel eine vision von europa oder
wollte einfach nur frankreich zur
absoluten vormacht in europa machen egal
wie mit feuer und schwert was was war da
bei napoleon
natürlich hat er visionen aber da er
immer in bewegung warum da die
konstellation sich immer änderten de
facto unter seiner herrschaft musste er
seine visionen immer mehr anpassen und
seine träume wurden immer mehr auch zu
alpträumen vor allem für die zeigen
lassen aber die vision wenn er eine
hatte das war das hat ja selber gesagt
zu lebzeiten und später als er gefangen
waren auf sagt elena das war frankreich
zuerst frankreich zuerst frankreich als
eben frankreich als die größte macht in
europa und ein frankreich das von seiner
übermacht profitiert das heißt die
reformen die in vielen anderen ländern
durchgeführt worden sind und nicht nur
in der deutschsprachigen sind und
genauso in spanien oder in italien die
waren da damit die verbündete die zwangs
verbündete frankreich helfen können
in seiner macht politik und damit die
franzosen nicht zu sehr durch die last
der kriege und der finanzierung der
eroberung belastet werden
das war eben das entscheide und es gibt
über die paradoxie der geschichte garner
hagemann erwähnte vorhin die großen
reformen in preußen
aber diese große reform sieht einfach
die übernahme im besiegten frankreich
alle reformen die frankreich während der
option zeit und zu beginn der polnischen
zeit durchgeführt hatte mit einem
gewaltigen unterschied
diese reformen waren nicht für
frankreich sondern gegen frankreich die
waren nicht im geiste der französischen
revolution sondern gegen den geist der
französischen revolution
wir haben eben mehrfach schon vom genie
napoleon gesprochen dass sich natürlich
vor allem in seiner tätigkeit als
feldherr dann auszeichnete woran
bestanden denn da seine qualitäten
nehmen wir doch mal die vielleicht
berühmteste schlacht die schlacht von
austerlitz was war da sein spezielles
wir exakt mancini also das schreien des
mythischen hieß muss man auf
verschiedenen struktur allen ebenen
beantworten zunächst einmal ist
profiteur der entwicklungen die mit der
französischen revolution im militärwesen
eingesetzt haben die lakers hat also
eine enorme heeres aufregung
hervorgebracht es gab praktische
innovationen die orden mixed die alle
verschiedene aufstellungen miteinander
verband es gab technische innovationen
wie zum beispiel einfach einer
berittenen artillerie
das waren erstmal alles struktur
bedingungen auf die napoleon dann
aufbauen konnte er war ja akku leer ist
und er war ist und das hat natürlich in
seiner konkreten taktik immer eine sehr
große rolle gespielt
ein zweiter punkt wäre dann seine
eigenen reformen im taktischen vorgehen
er zum beispiel unterschiedliche armee
kurs gebildet die die separat
voneinander operierten die also alle mit
infanterie kavallerie batterie
ausgestattet waren die sehr autonom
operieren konnten und dann am
entscheidenden punkt zusammen kamen
das ist genau der punkt der aufbau
ausland wird ein weitere strategie in
der police war schnell in das
gegnerische territorium einzudringen den
gegner dazu zu nötigen eine schlacht zu
liefern
er ist also über wien schließlich dann
bis nach ausgekommen mit diesen
separaten leeres gruppen hat dann einen
bluff gemacht und den gegner in einer um
fassung aktion sozusagen von der seite
oder von hinten gekriegt und dann kam
das was ihn als als juristen geprägt hat
nämlich diese massive gong batterien in
der mitte sozusagen zu positionieren und
er hat gesagt eine schlacht zu gewinnen
ist ähnlich wie eine festung einzunehmen
man muss ein
in den gegner hineintreiben muss eine
bresche schießen und das ging nur mit
massiven artillerie einsatz der
artillerie war sehr mobil und wurde dann
konzentriert an einer stelle eingesetzt
und den gegner dort sozusagen wind zu
schlagen
auch wenn es sich um eine viel größere
gegnerische armee gehandelt hat das ist
das was man dann eben als genial findet
mit einer unterlegenen streitmacht als
jetzt quantitativ unterlegenen
streitmacht eine viel größere
streitmacht tatsächlich zu besiegen und
das geht eben nur in dieser
konzertierten aktion unterschiedliche
hilfsgruppen dann einem entscheid
anschlag an einer entscheidenden stelle
der gegner gerät in unordnung wird
nervös und dann hat napoleon
gewissermaßen alle macht den sack
zuzumachen und mit seiner niederwerfung
strategie sozusagen den gegner
vollständig zu besiegen und in folge
eines solchen vollständigen sieges in
einen diktator reden so lancieren und
damit seine expansionsstrategie auf
diese weise erfolgreich zu warum
erinnert mich das was sie sagen in
gewisser weise an die strategien und
taktiken der wehrmacht in den jahren 39
bis 41 ja als historiker hat man ja
sozusagen da immer große schwierigkeiten
auf solche analogien einzugehen
ich würde erstmal sagen der bruder
wusste ja nichts von der wehrmacht dann
kommt natürlich diese blut beliebten
analogien hätte er das mit russland hat
man das gar nicht ahnen kann es weiter
das ist sehr müßig darauf einzugehen es
gibt natürlich solche militärischen
basis setzte was strategie taktik und
auch schnelligkeit angeht und da sind
dann auf einer strukturellen eben
natürlich solche analogien möglich
historisch würde ich sie immer möglichst
vermeiden weil man einfach da dinge
miteinander vergleicht die völlig
unvergleichbar sind und das auf so ner
abstraktionsebene sozusagen von
landkarten wo irgendwelche bunten
truppen und keine sozusagen aufeinander
kommt sieht das immer alles sehr ähnlich
aus der küche von hannibal über napoleon
wehrmacht oder caesar könnten wir alles
miteinander vergleichen
das aber nicht die art wie die
geschichtswissenschaft heute mit der
geschichte und kriegsgeschichte
sozusagen musst immer gesagt
der der am besten die strategie von der
polio verstand hat war ein preußischer
general richtig und clausewitz wurde
dann
eingehend studiert bei der ausbildung
der stabsoffiziere im 19
noch zu beginn dieses jahrhunderts und
wenn man die taktik und die strategie
von guderian vergleich mit der von
napoleon sind die ähnlichkeiten ziemlich
stark
das ist sozusagen naja die initiative
nie die initiative dem gegner überlassen
und am entscheidenden moment zuschlagen
um am ende eine entscheidungsschlacht
durchzuführen und das war eben die
überlegenheit von der polizei gegenüber
seinen gegner die gene oberhausen noch
menschen des achtzehnten jahrhunderts wo
man versucht einen gewissen vorteil
gegenüber dem gegen dazu haben aber
nicht unbedingt in total zu besiegen
napoleon als auch als sohn der
französischen revolution will den
totalen sieg deshalb auch und dafür sind
alle mittel recht
und so lange es eben gelungen ist war er
bis auf also gut dass die klausel wird
erwähnen das ist natürlich die
abstraktionsebene ich gerade meinte die
dadurch clausewitz erstmals erreicht
dass man den trip krieg auf allgemeine
prinzipien unterbricht und diese
allgemeinen prinzipien sind auch so in
einer abstrakten ebene angesiedelt dass
sie eben vergleichbarkeit herstellen die
eigentlich jetzt so nicht gegeben ist
dass er ganz andere ausrüstung haben die
körper der soldaten sind ganz anders die
gewehre die waffen sind anders die
mentalität ist eine andere und so weiter
ob man sozusagen das ganze noch als
göttliches strafgericht sieht oder im
säkularer welt aufgewachsen das sind
ganz andere strukturelle bedingungen
aber sie hat vollkommen recht über
clausewitz als theorie scharnier kommen
diese abstraktion schnell vernichtend
einen schlag zu führen natürlich auch in
die deutschen general stäbe und wirken
dann bis in das zeitalter der weltkriege
natürlich so hinein aber eben auf einer
theoretischen geben und sowohl als
lehrmeister der deutschen general stäbe
deshalb ich würde dazu führen dass wenn
man sich also die kriege von 18 13 bis
15 anguckt durchaus auch die
militärischen generäle
also die zeitgenossen von clausewitz da
er sein werk vom kriege erst so zu einem
posthum ist jetzt herausgegeben durchaus
genau auch schon versucht haben von
napoleon zu lernen von vereint lernen
heißt siegen lernen und das kann man
also wirklich von den preußischen
reformen sagen das heißt das ist nicht
erst durch die clausewitz rezeption
passiert sondern es ist eigentlich
interessanter weise schon sozusagen in
den in den letzten koalitions kriegen
angewandt worden und darüber
hinausgehend clausewitz ist ja nicht nur
von den deutschen generellen gelesen
wenn also jetzt in den usa in den
militärakademien clausewitz ist immer
noch pflichtlektüre und das hat also
auch schon im 19 jahrhundert begonnen
das heißt es ist hat eine sehr schnelle
breite rezeption unter anderem über
clausewitz aber auch über die lektüre
der französischen militär theoretiker
eingesetzt und was also interessant ist
und dem ganzen noch so kleinen dreh zu
geben
die deutschen historiker haben in der
zweiten hälfte des 19 jahrhunderts
spielt zum beispiel noch treffen denn
franzosen hass gepredigt in ihren
schriften die militärhistoriker der
preußischen krieg schule haben in der
gleichen zeit intensivst ja also das
genie von das militärische die von
napoleon studiert und also eine ganz
andere interpretation schon am ende des
19 jahrhunderts von napoleon gegeben
jetzt reden wir doch mal über etwas
friedlicheres nämlich seine schöpfung
den sogenannten rheinbund 16 glaube ich
waren das fürstentum rechts des rheins
vasallen von napoleon wenn man sich die
landkarte anguckt war das ja so ein
bisschen wie vorläufer der alten
bundesrepublik rechts und links das
große frankreich de gaulle und adenauer
was man in dieser rheinbund für napoleon
klausi ein vorfeld ein vasall oder doch
ein wichtiger bündnispartner alles
zusammen alles was wir alles zusammen
natürlich waren das künstliche
schöpfungen zu beginn die kanada
gegründet worden waren um die vormacht
von frankreich auf dem kontinent zu
stabilisieren und unter uns gesagt auch
als ausgleich für die niederlagen
frankreichs auf dem meer
es gab trafalgar vorher ja und dann war
sowas ausgleich da napoleon die briten
nicht mehr auf dem meer besiegen konnte
und wochen die einst eigentlichen
hauptfeinde von frankreich von beginn an
bis zum ende
dann versuchte er vorteile auf dem
kontinent zu haben
und dort wo die französische revolution
begonnen hatte die das linke rheinufer
gehörte zum königreich war voll
annektiert teilbereich zuerst als
schuldiger aber zur musik von sich zu
sagen ja zur republik und dann zum
kaiserreich und dann gründete der polio
und an der östlichen seite von
frankreich was zahlen und verbündete und
meiner klugen mischung von unterwerfung
und gleichzeitig von vorteilen für diese
neue machthaber
denn diese wenigen herrscher im
vergleich zu dem zustand vorher wo es
mehrere hunderte herrschaften gab
die hatten alle größere königreiche die
wurden alle aufgewertet zu königen die
wurden zu königin der könig von sachsen
der könig von narnia der könig von
württemberg
und wenn sie früher herzöge waren dann
wurde zu groß alle wurden aufgewertet
die reformen die sie durchsetzen mussten
auf druck von napoleon gaben ihnen auch
die möglichkeit mehr einkünfte zu haben
eine bessere verwaltung eine grössere
armee und sie haben auch von dem
größeren markt auf dem europäischen
kontinent profitiert das heißt es war
ein spiel in welchem
freiheit gewonnen hat aber die anderen
haben nicht verloren mindestens zu
beginn
und deswegen haben sie ihm die treue
gehalten weil sie wussten sie wäre zu
gefährlich als opfer denn da zu sein
zumal sie ganz ähnliche vorstellungen
teilte unter sich
er hat ein ganz ähnliches verständnis
der machtausübung der politik der
sozialen ordnung und so weiter
nun brachen alle untereinander
französisch sie erlebten jedenfalls nur
aber nicht nur die league nicht nur dem
auf dem schlachtfeld von leipzig 1813
die österreichischen die preußischen und
die russischen generäle haben
französisch untereinander gesprochen
das war die einzige gemeinsame sprache
und dadurch konnten sie den franz kaiser
besser besiegen
nun gab es östlich des rhein bundes ja
nach österreich und preußen die konnte
napoleon bewegen aber nicht abschaffen
nach dem sieg über preußen regt er ja
durch dieses schöne tore für hunde und
sehen als triumphator und als zeichen
seines sieges ließ er ja die quadriga
auf dem tor abbauen und nach paris dann
schicken
pure beute macherey oder ein wichtiges
historisches symbol wurde das den
klaglos hingenommen hier in greußen
würde klaglos eingenommen ja weil die
preußen oder die bewohner von berlin
keine andere möglichkeit hatten wenn man
total besiegt ist
der sieger kommt und setzt seinen willen
durch so etwas hat man in frankreich
nach 1940 erlebt nach der totalen
niederlage der dritten republik also das
wurde akzeptiert nicht unbedingt mit
großer freude aber das ist nur ein teil
einer größeren politik die nicht mit
napoleon begonnen hat und die man viel
früher schon verfolgen kann bis heute
die praxis der bau
kunst als folge des militärischen sieges
wenn heute so wunderschöne kunstwerke
der 17 jahre und das immer noch in
stockholm zu wehr wunden sind warum weil
die schweden im dreißigjährigen krieg
das bis nach park erobert haben
wenn die museen in frankreich aber auch
in anderen ländern viele kunst werten
aus anderen länder haben nicht nur weil
diese kunstwerke sauber gekauft worden
sind sondern auch sehr oft erobert
worden sind und neben dem transfer der
quadriga nach paris wo sie übrigens in
einer ecke im hof des schlosses louvre
weilte gab es natürlich sehr sehr viele
kunstwerke die sorgfältig ausgewählt
wurden
in den museen von berlin von potsdam von
braunschweig und von anderen städten wie
übrigens die französische revolution das
vorher gemacht hatte und wie der junge
napoleon das auch in italien gemacht hat
und für hitler es ab 49 auch ein
bisschen gemacht war ja wie das gering
doch das vermutlich napoleon und vor
allem seine berater einen viel besseren
kunstgeschmack der wichtigste mann in
dieser angelegenheit war wie worden und
hatte an dem ägypten feldzug von der
polizei genommen er gehört zu der gruppe
der gelehrten und wissenschaftler die
mit der dem feldzug nach ägypten auch
zur wiederentdeckung des alten ägyptens
beigetragen haben
er hat alles nachgezeichnet er war
selber ein künstler ein guter künstler
und die haben das in absprache mit deren
direktorin der riesigen museen und
einige der direktoren sagen ja wir haben
keine wahl
aber wenn unsere schöne kunstwerke am
ende alle in paris gesammelt sind im
louvre im sogenannten
napoleon da werden sie noch besser zur
geltung kommen und die europäische
öffentlichkeit wer sie dort am ende
besser bewundert können als in einem
versteckten verstaubten museum in der
deutschen provinz
bleiben wir doch mal in deutschen landen
frage man die erfahrungen mit der
französischen besatzung oder
beherrschung waren ja von region zu
region ganz unterschiedlich welche
unterschiede gab es denn da das hängt
der der britische kollege michael boris
spricht von inner and outer empire
also wenn man der der rhein bund wäre
sozusagen noch teil des imperialen
einflussbereiches und ich denke hier hat
der kollegin france war sehr genau
beschrieben dass und auch der kollege
marian füssel das ist vor allem die
oberen sozialen schichten in der
verwaltung im militär durchaus sehr
lange auch profitiert haben von einer
teilhabe an den imperialen kriegen wenn
man sich hingegen preußen anguckt ist
das schon mal ist es eine ganz andere
situation nach der niederlage von jena
und auerstedt 18.6 haben ganz viele
preußischen offiziere und beamte ihren
job verloren waren lange arbeitslos
universitäten wurden geschlossen die
professoren verloren verloren ihre
karrieren die okkupation hat das land
extrem ausgeblutet also wir haben also
ziemlich genaue zahlen und sehr viele
berichte
es gibt also es gibt so eine art polizei
berichte über die operationszeit und die
werden immer dramatischer und
dramatischer und der könig wird immer
mehr gewann komm endlich zurück ja damit
also das land zusammenhält
das heißt für die war das zunehmend
dramatisch und auch im rhein bund oder
auch selbst in hinter port moresby also
den hansestädten je mehr der krieg an
hilft den mehrkosten also finanzmittel
finanzielle mittel notwendig wurden die
mehr soldaten notwendig wurden desto
höher wurden die lasten und das heißt
das dann also auch vor allem also wir
haben protest der unterschichten
proteste schon 18 12 13 in allen
regionen
in teilen des königreichs westfalen in
hamburg in teilen von den okkupierten
teilen oder nicht mehr dann von preußen
das heißt vor allem die sozialen
unterschichten haben protestiert wir
haben auch in frankreich im übrigen aber
auch in der konfiguration im rhein bund
haben wir zunehmend der situation also
diese jungen männer wollten nicht mehr
beim heer dienen da gibt es umfangreiche
studien zu die sind gedeckt und
geschützt wurden von der bevölkerung die
mussten ihr versteckt werden oder sind
über die landesgrenzen gegangen deshalb
es gab eine zunehmende unwilligkeit wo
man kann also sagen der wendepunkt ist
so 18 19
ja also wo dann also sozusagen die
stimmung kippt und der russlandfeldzug
war ja selbst nicht nur für die
rheinbund staaten und alle alliierten
war es eine enorme herausforderung wenn
sie sich vorstelle 600.000 männer wenige
anhänger er das ist leipzig hatte 40.000
einwohner ungefähr an dieser zeit das
sind viele viele großstädte die da durch
diese gegend gezogen worden die sind wie
heuschrecken über diese territorien hier
gefallen die ihn pferde und kutschen und
getränke bier wein alles was also
sozusagen nötig war musste aus dem land
bereitgestellt worden
das heißt die unzufriedenheit nahm auf
allen seiten zu nehmen zu und ist dann
also sozusagen in 18 13 das kann man
sehen in preußen also auch wieder auf
grund der berichte zunehmend gekippt das
dann in dem moment wo also die
niederlage eingesetzt hat ja mit moskau
das war wirklich das signal dann auch
sozusagen die hoffnung bestand jetzt
können wir ihn also wirklich besiegen
und also die stimmung dann auch
zunehmend umgekippt es war natürlich
artikuliert also ich hab mir ja die
tagespresse breit angeguckt
flugschriften und lieder und gedichte
und auch kriegs predigten im breiten
maße das ist dann auch zu nehmen bereit
artikuliert worden weil dann auch im
zuge des krieges die zensur aufgehoben
worden also solange der zensur haben
dann konnte man also in der konnte im
rheinbund durfte alles gegen preußen
gesagt werden und gegen die briten aber
natürlich nichts gegen napoleon und in
dem moment an als dann der also kriso
zusagen zurück kam nach dem
russlandfeldzug ist die zensur auch de
facto aufgehoben worden und dann geht
wirklich eine flutwelle
von propaganda gegen napoleon los und
die bewegt sich dann mit der front
sozusagen richtung westen was natürlich
die einzelnen noten die 1 1
was wirklich die einfachen menschen
gedacht haben werden wir nicht erfahren
das ist immer unser problem demoskopie
die tatsache dass zum beispiel ganz
normale prediger ja also sozusagen in
ihren predigten also wirklich auch diese
kriege unterstützt haben dass es diese
kollekten gab dass 50 prozent der so der
der jungen studentin in den
universitäten als freiwillige die kriege
unterstützt haben 18 13 in preußen das
macht natürlich erstmal was also dass
man kann also wir haben eine lange
diskussion in der geschichtsschreibung
darüber ist dass eine neue nationale
bewegung oder nicht wie breit war die
unterstützung dieser antinapoleonischen
bewegung und der kriege das ist eine
ziemlich müßige diskussion denn also
dass da eine bewegung war
da gibt es genügend zeichen das war noch
nicht nationalistisch das war
patriotismus das war verteidigung des
vaterlandes das war verteidigung des
königs zum teil was auch
deutschnationaler nationalismus als
waren gemengen lage aber ich da so
wichtig ist eben wirklich das wäre sehr
genau uns ansehen wie hat sich die
stimmung verändert und die hat sich
dramatisch verändert er hat einfach er
war zu er war zu sehr to run up an
bestecken zeigt das dass die balance
zwischen um dieses dieser
gegenüberstellung aufzugreifen die
zwischen reformator und tyrannen die ist
irgendwann gekippt um 18.10
und natürlich gezeigt dass er nicht mehr
unbesiegbar richtig ganz wichtig und er
hatte eine halbe million soldaten
verloren in russland vorsorge von 4.500
wochen verloren und dante viele deutsche
wanderer aber interessanterweise die
mobilisierung 18 13 das ist ja eine
leistung wenn man sich überlegt wie viel
also sind 25.000 sozusagen von den
alliierten sind zurückgekommen wirklich
dieses die leistung wieder ein so großes
heer zu mobilisieren bis august ja oder
auch früher
das hat natürlich in starkem maße dann
auch die frankreich getroffen das heißt
da war frankreich und da gibt es neue
untersuchungen in erheblichem maße das
erste mal
sozusagen ganz starke zu einem zeitpunkt
vorher hat es sich natürlich über langen
zeitraum verteilt aber wirklich in einem
zeitpunkt massen aushebung und das hat
auch in frankreich dann zu widerstand
und protest und situationen steigen
also auf einer polen bezogen auf
napoleon bezogen in dem maße wie der
tyrann in ihm doch mehr und mehr wächst
verliert sich offenbar das militärische
schäden nehmen wir zum beispiel doch die
völkerschlacht von leipzig 1813
was hat er denn da falsch gemacht hätte
ja es ist ein bisschen schwierig das auf
einzelne personen und einzelne
entscheidungen unter zu brechen muss die
vorgeschichte natürlich sehen den
russlandfeldzug auch die erfolge der der
alliierten im vorfeld auch die
erschöpfungszustände der französischen
armee und auch diese gewaltige größe der
dort aufeinander treffenden armee
vorhang manischen das kleinen leipzig
sozusagen und diese wenigen großstädte
drumherum
allein inter mit den ganzen leichen und
verwundeten und toten umzugehen war eine
bestialische überforderung der stadt
leipzig obwohl und hat uns dort sehr
traditionell agiert aber ich glaube
nicht dass man sagen kann er hat irgend
eine großartige fehlentscheidung
getroffen sondern man muss das so zu
sagen sehr stark in dem unmittelbaren
kontext der kampagne davor sehen die wo
sich also zu sagen ein schwächer werden
bereits abzeichnete wahrheit gesicht er
hat ja der hat seit august praktisch von
august bis oktober hatte eine schlacht
nach der anderen bereits gewonnen
die ersten alliierten bayern haben dann
anfang oktober schon die fronten
gewechselt und also während der schlacht
selber waren war nur noch baden und
sachsen auf seiner seite und de facto
haben dann weil also die sächsischen
soldaten wenig lust hatten gegen ihre
eigenen landsleute aus dem schlachtfeld
sein
sich umgedreht das war eine stimmung
sache also ich würde auch es war
erschöpfung es war aber auch ein stück
militär militärische sie gewährten auch
unter hat clausewitz vollkommen recht
werden natürlich auch mit mit der
begeisterung und der unterstützung der
kampfmoral der soldaten begonnen und
stiefeln auf seiten napoleons
niedersächsische verrat nicht noch bis
heute in frankreich
wenn die franzosen die ich nach bei
leipzig verloren haben da sind die
sachsen schuld wenn sie die schlacht bei
waterloo verloren haben da ist natürlich
napoleon die schuld sondern mit general
mein gruß
darüber reden wir noch reden dann
nochmal über die taster sie haben das
beide erwähnt dass die rheinbund staaten
nun fluchtartig sozusagen die fahne
verließen war das reiner opportunismus
oder in den raum und stand auch schon so
ein element des neu erwachenden
nationalbewusstseins dass sie ja gesagt
hat ich würde ein nationalismus würde
ich nicht sehen dass man bewusst nicht
ab sondern einfach nein das war
überlebensstrategie die hatten sehr viel
von der bolero profitiert verdanken ihm
alle und auf einmal sehen sie dass der
große protektor der ihnen vieles
geschenkt hat nicht mehr so mächtig ist
dass er möglicherweise dabei ist das
ganze zu verlieren
und man will die errungenschaften
behalten und der einzige mittel der
übrig bleibt ist auf die andere seite zu
gehen und noch rechtzeitig der einzige
der nicht recht hat sich gemacht hat war
der könig von sachsen als letztes glaube
ich und dadurch er wurde gefangen
genommen um dann bei den verhandlungen
in
wien hat er fast die hälfte seines
goethe kreis verloren
der könig von bayern war genauso kreuz
und napoleon hat genauso viele soldaten
geopfert es gibt noch ein großes denkmal
mitten in münchen was daran erinnert
aber er wusste rechtzeitig die seite zu
wechseln so dass er nicht bestraft wurde
das reine überleben eine überlegung
story wird von den staaten von den
eliten aber wie saas denn mit dem
einfachen volk aus ich nehme jetzt mal
preußen dazu meine es gibt von vielen
zeugnissen her gesehen eines moritz an
viele andere so sehr patriotische
aufwallungen in der zeit
das hängt wirklich von der sozialen
schicht ab für preußen ist ich rede
nicht von nationalismus ich rede von
patriotisch nationalen gemengen konsum
ja und franzosen hast ja aber ihr werdet
also während des krieges während der
kriegsjahre 18 13 ist in der propaganda
ganz stark seine mischung aus deutsche
kulturnation und preußischen
patriotismus propagiert worden mit dem
ziel einheit herzustellen auch zwischen
den verschiedenen deutschen regionen ja
und die geeint werden sollten und
mussten im kampf gegen napoleon
ganz stark war in der propaganda der
antifranzösische und antinapoleonischen
gedanke und ganz stark war der
christliche gedanke also es ist ein
heiliger krieg gegen den gottlosen
tyrannen napoleon geführt worden und
diese auflage also auch die amischen wer
lieder zum beispiel haben beachtliche
auflage von 100.000 exemplaren gehabt
sind an die armeen an die soldaten
verteilt worden sind in den
die lieder sind in den kirchen gesungen
worden das heißt es ist von den in die
von den gebildeten nicht von den
machteliten die haben strategisches
machtkalkül für einen seitenwechsel hat
aber von den gebildeten schon sind sehr
stark patriotisch nationale gedanken
geteilt und propagiert war sogar
napoleon sozusagen der wecker und
beabsichtigt eines neuen neu erwachenden
deutschen patriotismus ist ja es neu
erwacht es gab natürlich nationales
gedankengut schon an
seit der renaissance aber ich würde
schon sagen es ist bewusst auch geweckt
worden also zu die die preußischen
reformer beispielsweise und in
zusammenarbeit mit den patrioten haben
schon vor 18 13 lange darüber diskutiert
wie man denn patriotisch entschuldigung
patriotismus erwecken kann und haben
also wirklich systematisch schulen
propaganda kirchen eingesetzt dafür weil
ihnen klar war der ist diese form der
massenmobilisierung und die einführung
der allgemeinen wehrpflicht im märz 18
13 nicht möglich ist wenn da nicht eine
breitere unterstützung ist und
gleichzeitig was auch interessant ist
wenn ich auch finanzielle und materielle
unterstützung auch der bevölkerung also
auch der zivilbevölkerung führt diese
kriege möglich ist denn post über
bankrott die brauchten das geld durch
steuern und abgaben sonst hätten die
nicht krieg führen kann
und die brauchten auch die ausrüstung
und bekleidung der freiwilligen
unterland wäre das wurde nicht vom staat
finanziert das wurde über die gemeinden
finanziert das heißt die die landwehr
ist von unten aufgebaut worden und da
muss das konnte man nicht nur von oben
durchsetzen da musste man unterstützung
auf dem stück in den gemeinden haben und
die ist da gibt es große unterschiede je
nachdem was für erfahrungen die in einer
kooperation gemacht haben und den
kriegen gemacht haben wie viel negative
erfahrungen die haben aber da sind die
unterstützungs zahlen für die einzelnen
provinzen preußisch zum teil ganz
beeindruckend waren das denn und
freiheitskriege oder waren es
befreiungskriege darüber für lange
gestritten worden was war das auch da
würde ich ihn gegen marian schlüssel
anschließen es ist sie sprechen von
kriegen von 18 13 bis 15 war diese
beiden begriffe schon in der kriegszeit
so ideologisch besetzt waren
das so zu sagen welchen begriff wie auch
immer nehmen wir also partei ergreifen
das möchte ich nicht was was wir
feststellen können ist das vor allem für
die deutschen die kleine relativ kleine
gruppe gebildeter deutschnationaler
patrioten waren es freiheitskriege die
gehofft haben
mit der unterstützung dieser kriege auch
mehr politische freiheitsrechte nach den
kriegen zu gewinnen und sie hoffen ja
nicht nur auf freiheiten sie hat ja viel
eine deutsche einheit es wurde ja doch
letzten endes schmählich enttäuscht war
das doch ein trauerfall in der deutschen
geschichte in runde
was man sehr viel lächeln trauerfall ist
sehr schwierig zu bezeichnen
es kommt darauf an was wie man sich
einen idealzustand für deutschland
vorstellen
und heutzutage sind wir uns nicht alle
darüber einig und in dieser zeit noch
weniger wie haben wir viel von preußen
gesprochen und zwar zu recht
aber deutschland bestand nicht nur aus
preußen und dem rhein bund sondern auch
aus österreich österreich war mindestens
genauso wichtig und kann die nationale
bewegung wurde zuerst von wien aus
gestartet ehe sie später von berlin aus
gefördert wurde
vergessen wir nicht auch den aufstand
von andreas hofer raßhofer ist auch ein
anderer ausdruck der region gegenüber
macht übrigens anti neidisch hat die
bayerisch und nicht gehe ja aber von den
franzosen erschossen
in mantua gott hat mich von den bayern
das zeigt dass also eine ideale
vorstellung von deutschland kann man
nicht haben und was man wieder sehr gut
sieht in dieser zeit ist dieses
spannungsverhältnis was es schon vor der
französischen revolution gab zwischen
preußen und österreich wehrt wird die
führende macht in den deutschen länder
und seit gut keiner der beiden
königreich einerseits kaiserreich
andererseits wach stark genug um sich
durchzusetzen so dass eben
unterschiedliche vorstellungen
miteinander konkurrierten auf
politischer ebene wie auch auf
emotionaler ebene reden wir zum
abschluss doch nummer über napoleons
letzte schlacht erfüllte er hat sie
verloren das wissen wir ja wort hallo in
belgien
aber das war ja nun nicht unbedingt
zwangsläufig welche fehler hatte er denn
da gemacht
beliebte frage man kann eigentlich sagen
dass genau das was sonst ein
erfolgsrezept war diesmal extrem
fehlgeschlagen ist also die erste maxime
war den gegner zu aufzuteilen also die
wie temperatur und herrsche das war auch
militärisch sein credo auf keinen fall
sollten sich die alliierte britisch
niederländische armee mit der
preußischen armee vereinigen
wir wissen ist es doch am späten
nachmittag gelungen diese vereinigung
das war also soll es ein plan der nicht
aufgegangen ist ein anderer plan war mit
dieser batterie also der massierten
artillerie in der mitte die briten
gewissermaßen sturmreif zu schießen das
ist nicht aufgegangen weil das wetter
nicht mitgespielt hat das ganze war eine
riesen mutter an ein macho zu sagen wie
sie es hat den ganzen tag vorher die
ganze nacht geregnet erst gegen 11 uhr
konnten die kampfhandlungen eigentlich
beginnen statt um 8 oder um sieben uhr
früh morgens
das bedeutet der artillerie einsatz wie
eigentlich vorgesehen war konnte in
dieser form gar nicht stattfinden
dann hatte sich verlinken das muss man
auch berücksichtigen ist es nicht nur
die immer die frage welche fehler hat
napoleon gemacht sondern wie schlau war
möglicherweise auch sein gegner das wird
dann immer unterstellt dass es
eigentlich nur versagen des sees gelegen
hat und nicht möglicherweise auch einem
ganz trockenen kalkül des briten der
sich das dahinter in einer leichten
anhöhe seien sicher verschanzt hatte
und die franzosen im prinzip sie haben
sich den ganzen tag tot gerannt
sozusagen in dieser in diesem match
gegenüber den briten und das hat dann
nach dem eintreffen der preußen
natürlich auch noch sozusagen alle
anderen von der seite dazu geführt dass
langsam die französische armee immer
mehr erwartet ist und heute wird immer
wieder diskutiert ja wie es mit der
alten garde und so weiter das ist wird
man heute etwas differenzierter als dass
man so sagen diesen den heroischen kampf
bis zum letzten mann thematisiert man
sieht aber gerade still aber sie ergibt
sich dass sie deutlich stabiler und
länger angehört was sagen ausgeharrt hat
als das landläufig ist also das ist
nicht die panik nicht so früh eingesetzt
aber natürlich ist irgendwann auch dass
die letzte mobilisation von napoleon als
sie den jungen gerade die alte gerade
sozusagen ins feld geführt worden und
die waren tatsächlich erschöpft aber
gesagt zu den fehlern kann man sagen
sein erfolgsrezept wo er sich sehr
sicher war das wird auch hier passieren
das erfolgsrezept aus verschiedenen
gründen die mit dem territorium
zusammenhängen also wie das schlachtfeld
eigentlich materiell sich gestaltet die
aber auch mit anderen mit der
kommunikation zusammenhängen mit gucci
erwähnt wir also ganz woanders weilte
und ihn nicht unterstützen konnte das
hatte er hinter natürlich extrem übel
genommen und das sozusagen als
unfähigkeit oder vielleicht sogar bösen
willen ausgelegt aber das war das was
man mit klausens infektionen nennt also
unvorhergesehene zwischenfälle
die eine solche schlacht eigentlich
ausmachen einem schlag besteht
eigentlich mehr aus solchen fraktionen
als aus genauen plänen die dann genauso
wie auf dem papier sich in der realität
entfalten in der deutschen literatur
wurde ja gleichwohl lange zeit immer
gern darauf verwiesen dass es die
preußen gewesen sein und der bücher die
die schlacht entschieden hätten und er
wird ja gerne immer dieser spruch
zitiert ob er so gefallen ist wissen
wenn ich von wellington ich wollte es
wären acht oder die preußen kämen
in großbritannien sieht man nun die
frage wer war der eigentliche sieger
völlig anders als sie wie war das denn
aus ihrer sicht
interessanterweise ist hat sich da wie
in vielen anderen fragen die wir
diskutiert haben im verlauf der letzten
200 jahre die interpretation sehr
geändert bücher ist als großer held von
waterloo in london
in den monaten nach der schlacht
gefeiert worden es gab also paraden es
gab bälle es gab empfängen es gab
gedenkmünze und er ist überall in der
presse gewesen und also sozusagen diese
aneignung die der erinnerung der
schlacht also als britischen sich das
hat dann also sozusagen erst in den
nächsten jahrzehnten stattgefunden und
also wenn man selber der große sieger
ist dann leicht man auch gerne dazu die
leistungen der koalitionspartner zurück
zuzusagen runter zu setzen das gilt im
übrigen ja nicht nur für auch wenn man
jetzt mal die ganzen kriege sich 18 13
15 an guckt nicht nur für österreich was
immer gerne vergessen wird sondern
genauso für russland also die
beteiligung von russland also die
leistung von russland an diesen kriegen
und auch an dem sieg über napoleon ist
eigentlich erst in den letzten zehn
jahren von der geschichtsschreibung
wirklich auch wahrgenommen und anerkannt
worden
das heißt dass interpretation verändern
sich sehr schnell sechs jahre nach der
niederlage otto starb napoleon
änderung auf der insel st nun hätte man
ja denken können dass die franzosen
vielleicht doch froh gewesen wären dass
sie ihn bei all den vielen opfern die
seine zeit gefordert hat überwunden
hätten stattdessen wurden seine gebeine
20 jahre später triumphierend nach paris
überführt
wie kommt es denn dass dieser mann trotz
aller leichenberge die ja verursacht hat
dennoch nationalheld wurde und bleibt
und bleibt umstritten
und deswegen ist seine erinnerung auch
lebendig weil sie nicht eindeutig ist
es gibt in frankreich viele personen die
ihn bewundern für seine leistung sei es
im in frankreich oder auch für seine
feldzüge aber auch viele andere die ihn
überhaupt nicht mögen
wir haben in frankreich eine
republikanische verfassung die dritte
republik nach der niederlage der zweiten
in der lage von 1870 übrigens von
preußischen general generieren auch
durchgeführt die die lehren aus der
polio gezogen hatten die dritte republik
wollte die erinnerungen der polio
verbannen und ladezeit wurde sie verband
aber in breiten schichten der
bevölkerung blieb er als der große held
und vor allem nicht nur weil er gesiegt
hatte und frankreich die macht gegeben
hatte sondern auch weil er am ende
besiegt worden
das heißt er war gleichzeitig ein held
und ein märtyrer und da die
nachkommenden nicht so glänzend waren
machten von diesem mann aus deutscher
sicht verfüge
das sind eine ganze vielzahl von
aspekten ich denke die der rechts
reformer der der kurze will auch brille
genannt ist gerade in der in der
deutschen rechtsgeschichte immer wieder
umstritten gewesen es gab also viele
befürworter es gab dann auch herrsche
gegner wie savigny das als große
schweinerei bezeichnet hatte
es kam eine ganz bizarre rezeption im
nationalsozialismus wo man das als
germanisches recht identifizierte das
lag an nordfranzösischen
gewohnheitsrecht was ein geschlossenes
also
ganz ambivalente und wechselhafte
rezeption dieser dieser rechts reformen
hier vor allem in den randländern
sozusagen auch eine gewisse
dauerhaftigkeit hatten das wäre also
einmal die dieser dieser aspekt dann in
der das nur von ferrari schon ausgeführt
diese diese effekte dieser paradoxen
effekt da sozusagen in diesen latenten
patriotismus und dann in nation offene
nationalismus sozusagen über schlagen zu
lassen das wird auch natürlich erinnert
gewissermaßen und im bereich der
militärgeschichte das haben wir auch
schon diskutiert
clausewitz vor tausenden und auch die
folgen ist natürlich napoleon immer als
deren große feldherr auch in der
deutschen presse in der deutschen
geschichte im deutschen mit teresa
grafen gewürdigt worden
mit allen ambivalenten folgen dieser
dieser deutung und im 19
zum beispiel ist noch immer mit
friedlich den zwei verglichen worden und
es wurde gefragt wer ist der größere
friedrich der große oder napoleon wo ja
nie der große genannt
aber die deutschen haben dann auch einen
eigenen diskurs entwickelt wie sie diese
beiden figuren immer wechselseitig
miteinander verglichen haben was also
zeigt dass auch die würdigung das
sozusagen imperialen eroberers militärs
immer neben dem rechts reformer und dem
neu ordner sozusagen der europäischen
territorien eine rolle spielt wir haben
noch eine minute frei hagemann war
dieser mann von dem wir reden denn als
der große tor des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts auch in gewisser hinsicht
zu einem vorbild für die welt an und uhr
super toren des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
anknüpfend an das was ich vorher gesagt
habe für militärische fixed für kriegs
theoretiker und für militär schulen in
der gesamten welt war er durchaus als
genialer feldherr lange lange ein
vorbild und so ist er auch erinnert
worden
wir sehen das heute ein bisschen anders
und was wir eben tun als historiker ist
wirklich auch diese europäischen kriege
auch in ihren kolonialen kontext zu
setzen denn das hatten wir haben wir
heute nicht diskutiert dass es aber
wichtig dass natürlich dass ein teil des
großen hundertjährigen konfliktes im
achtzehnten jahrhundert zwischen
großbritannien und frankreich war aus
dem frankreich als siegreiche nation und
große kolonialmacht und welt beherrschen
hervorgegangen ist insofern
wir wollen das jetzt als perspektiven
und napoleon ist nicht mehr ganz so
erfolgreich dass unsere mal gesagt
geschichte ist die lüge auf die man sich
geeinigt hat so sagt das wort er wir
sehen das selbstverständlich völlig
anders in reihen danke ich für ihre
interessanten aussagen und ihnen liebe
zuschauer
danke ich für ihr interesse bleiben sie
uns treu